I'm going to go to the next room.
So this is me, this is me, this is me, this is me, this is me, this is me, he is me.
Right three two one hey, one and the two, that's me.
and the two don't care what I'm painting.
It's me, me, I'm drawing the colors, you have to do it for anything.
Check, check, check. Hello. Hello. This is me talking. Hello. Yeah, right? Three, two, one. Hello. Check, check, check, check. All right. Cool. So let me show you the other one.
Check, check, check, check. Oh, stay out. Yeah, stay on this one. Check, check, check. Audio check. Hello. Hello. Hello. Yeah. Sounds good.
Just took a minute to dial it in. So just remember, if you do start to hear double feedback or some popping, just write bottom two.
Write those down. Depending on what you want to get.
They're the main, this is the main.
Stream, stream.
Stream could hear you.
Tempering is a new system that allows you to really customize the gear that you find.
In order to temper, you will need to go to the blacksmith and then choose the recipe that you wish temper from.
And then a random aphics from that recipe will be attached onto your gear.
Tempering recipes can be found from almost all of the content throughout sanctuaries.
So you will actually be looking for tempering recipes that go directly with what you're envisioning.
They're all going to be recipes that are more generic and maybe are just generally good for the sorceress,
but you'll be able to choose which one you think is going to be most powerful with the build you're making for your class.
We're making a pretty radical change to the codex of power in this season, based again on the feedback that has been coming from our players.
Every single legendary in the game will be entered into your codex of power so that you can continually imprint the best possible version of that legendary onto your gear.
So going forward, there will no longer be carrying around all of these aspect crystals in your inventory.
It's all going to be in the codex of power.
So part of the final system that we have is going to be greater aphics.
What's a greater aphics?
Well, we want to keep it compelling that there are some drops that are even better than the others when you're trying to get the perfect build at endgame.
Because of this, in World Tier 4 and only in World Tier 4, when an ancestral legendary item drops, there's a chance the aphics is on it can roll as greater aphics is.
These will roll with bigger values that are normally available for that aphics.
Greater aphics are fairly rare, but they're not impossible to find.
While leveling up, you're going to be able to find upgrades much more easily with this new system.
Another part of itemization is going to be master working.
Now this is something really intended for that very high endgame, again, World Tier 4.
This is where a player is going to take an item.
R.E. has the aphics that they won on it, but now they go through a process of upgrading those aphics.
Getting even higher values on them.
Master working really starts at level 100.
Once you've already completed your build and found some of the best items, you're going to be able to test your build against powerful enemies of the pit.
The pit is a new endgame system that has been added in this season, that is going to challenge players that feel that they have largely maximize their build.
By pushing into more difficult tiers of the pit, you're going to be able to unlock rare crafting materials to master work your gear even further.
You're going to have to play some of the hardest content in the game, but once you do, if you're successful, you can go and make those aphics even stronger.
In season 4, we're ramping the intensity of the health tides through the inclusion of a variety of new activities, the first of which is a doubling down and rise of the cultists presence throughout the tide.
You're going to be running through the health tides, saying the cultists just conjuring up swarms and swarms of demons, adding to that sense of manic and chaos that they're pretty well known for.
The other archetype that we're adding is the presence of the Doomsayers, who were unfortunate enough to be caught out in the tide and basically just lost their minds to all of the mania going on around them.
And lastly, rounding out the new activities are just the inclusion of the iron wolves. They're finally joined the fight, it could no longer stand in the sidelines, seeing the health tides and health forces intensify their assault on sanctuary.
As season 4 players engage and progress through the called the wolves seasonal activity, they'll earn honor with the iron wolves, unlocking access to a vast assortment of rewards to accompany and empower your season 4 journeys.
In the updated health tides for players who are able to stay alive long enough, they'll be paid a visit by the Hellbarn.
Former heroes of sanctuary who have aligned with the forces of hell to attack the allies they once aligned with.
Players who are able to take down the Hellbarn will be acquiring the materials they need to engage with the new premier, Haltide activity, the accursed rituals.
Located in the Helltide, these accursed rituals are pretty much just botched rituals from the cultists that players will be kickstarting for themselves, drawing the intention of all the nearby Helltide monsters in this kind of all-out battle.
One of my favorite themes for these ambushes is the Hellworm. It's literally a giant hell slug beast that emerges from the ground but it spews out a whole bunch of mobs at you.
If you're able to survive that, you'll be paid a visit from the Blood Maiden, our brand new Helltide mini-boss and one of the ultimate challenges in the new experience.
So I think I'm actually most excited about this season because of what you're able to do with your old characters, how they can integrate with this new item game and take them to new levels of power with this system.
I think that the best part of this update is that you're going to be really empowered to build the character that you want to play.
You're going to be able to pick custom affixes and enhance your character in a lot of new and interesting ways.
Alright.
We were just watching a video and they were all like,
Hey guys, how's it going? Welcome to another Diablo 4 developer update live stream. My name is Adam Pledgeur.
I am the community director here for Diablo. I'm joined by this wonderful panel plus an additional head which we will haul out.
We have four seats.
We have to do the same thing we did during the PTR stream which was like we swapped out like Joe Shelley, I put in Adam Jackson.
That's true. We're going to play more magic tricks today. Do you guys want to do a quick intro to yourself to the wonderful Diablo community?
Sure. I'm Joe Pippora on the associate game director for Diablo 4.
And I'm Adam Jackson, the lead live class designer for Diablo 4. And we have a new face.
I'm Colin Feiner. I'm the lead live game designer. Awesome. And then we're actually going to be joined by Derek.
For you.
Well, I already introduced myself. He dismissed it because he's an artist. I'm just going to swap her while terrible.
It's my first break.
But we actually have Derek who will be joining us as well. Derek, you just saw in the video prior talking about season 4.
He'll be swapping in to talk a little bit more about halterd's later in this.
But big stream here. We have season 4 coming up. As you guys saw earlier this week, it is luke reborn for season 4.
And a lot of players actually got to experience it a couple weeks ago with PTR.
This was our first Diablo 4. PTR was a massive undertaking from the team here.
But it was really, really great to have players jump in early.
Check out season 4 and all the changes and actually provide feedback.
And so we have a lot to cover today based off of feedback that we received from players from PTR itself.
But Joe, I know you wanted to jump into kind of talking a little bit more about season 4, how PTR went before we jump into all the changes.
Yeah, happy to.
So, okay. So last time we were on stream, we were actually talking about a lot of the changes that players were going to get.
So we just had to check out on the PTR. So we think that went really, really well.
It was just having the week of time for players to just jump in and just crush through all the content.
Check out all the new features and it gets a lot of feedback. Find a lot of bugs on the way as well.
It was again super valuable. It's been really, really great for the team.
We'll take a lot of these, this feedback. Look at the tuning variety of features.
And really make sure that we've got the best version of the season 4 experience ready when we get into the launch state.
So, in terms of our big takeaways, first of all, really, really valuable across the board.
Season 4, season 3, we were born was, as I mentioned, during the PTR stream originally, was really our opportunity to go back and take a lot of feedback in that we've been looking at since the launch of the game from 2023.
Sorry, it is so good.
I do love the KERK for this KERK for season 3 was awesome as well.
So, look you back at the launch. Thanks for disrupting my flow.
Thanks for watching.
Thank you so much.
Look you back at the launch of the project in 2023.
We got a lot of really good feedback.
Remember back in season 2, season 2, we made a big change to vulnerable damage and the multiplicative damage that comes along with it made a change to the way the elements of resist worked.
There were a lot of things we had to do to make those changes really shine through.
There were a lot of Paragon nodes that had to get updated.
There were a lot of like, allegatory aspects that had to get changed.
There was a lot of itemization stuff in the background.
We had to do to make those systems work better and lift up other things around them like overpower, for example, to make that feel like it was in a better spot.
So, now that we're looking at, even when we're done that one big release for season of blood, we knew that there's a lot more that we wanted to do.
Again, we've been thinking about.
But there's a lot of work we need to do to make sure that all of these things really all fit together cohesively.
So, as people got a chance to see on the PTR, the introduction of things like the tempering feature, which we're going to talk a little bit more in a minute,
we need to introduce these new affixes into items.
And, affixes you can't get at items anymore.
The reduction, affix, count on items overall.
So, it's a lot easier to go and sort through 25 pairs of gloves in your inventory at any given time.
You don't really have those same situations.
We reduced the number of items that drop in the game experience overall, but made sure that the items that are dropping are just more valuable and more likely to be upgrades for you,
or something you could kind of like build into an upgrade.
We introduced the master working feature, right?
And Colin helps out a lot of these things up right during, well, working with the teams.
So, they introduced the master working feature where players can continually upgrade items to increase the value of the affixes,
and then it ranks 4 and 8 and 12 until I kind of crit on one of these and make them even better.
Now, there's a lot of things we're introduced.
We add the new content type in the form of the Pity Artifester.
It's like this new extremely deep and deadly dungeon dive players get to go into once they get into the, towards the end game,
when you're going to like, you know, 85, 90, your character level, you're starting to kind of dip into that space.
And that's where you go to get your master working materials, which feels really, really good.
And we learned a lot of really great lessons from like greater riffs in Diablo 3,
which is really cool content there.
It's really, really fun things there.
Also, the codex of power updates, you know, long time to save all your legendaries all the time.
Codex of power updates, which I would like to be fair, I've been so excited about the codex of power updates.
I've been teasing it for like six livestreams.
Like, I feel like I teased it at the end of a livestream.
So, just what it is.
But again, super excited about the codex of power changes.
That is very transformational.
Like now, when legendary drops on the ground for you, you just salvage it, you get that aspect.
And then you're codex at the role that you got.
And you just get to use it in perpetuity.
And we actually have some fun ways.
We'll talk about later how we're playing with that a little bit as we go.
So, I mean, all of this stuff and more, we made huge, huge changes to Hellside.
I know Derek's been talking about it in a little while.
I see, he helped lead the team, did a lot of work for that.
And we got to introduce the season theme in the form of like looper-borne.
And then the reintroduction of the animals mercenaries, the players,
be working with during the course of the police.
And I know that we showed a little bit of that off earlier.
And I am just, personally, I was really, really excited about the release overall.
As this was an opportunity for us to work with like not just the season team,
but also the live team and the live loss work from the systems groups.
And there's a lot of things being done for the expansion.
That's coming out eventually as well, like Vessel hatred.
So, being able to like, really organize teams and make sure that we're in a really, really good spot
to like provide this really big update for the game.
It has been very, very exciting.
And the feedback, going back to the feedback.
The feedback from PTR was again really, really valuable.
It was great to get players in there and to get those things to take care.
And we're going to talk about some of those things today.
I know that some of this information has been like,
we talked to like a few, like press outlets, we talked to a few different people,
and like some information is getting out there.
But I want to make sure we can provide a little bit more detail, you know,
because I know this is the audience wants to know like the real specifics.
We're going to get into it, right?
And we'll also have our Q&A as we usually do at the end.
We'll be able to get like, answer some more questions the community might have
as we kind of give them the whole thing.
So, yeah, that was the, at a high level,
that's what we were feeling about the PTR, feeling pretty good about it.
I'm happy to like maybe jump into itemization or how do we go?
Yeah, I think the first thing we probably want to talk about is like,
the itemization changes that are in season four,
that people experience, which includes like the tempering,
the master working stuff that changed in season four.
And of course, all the feedback that we got from both tempering,
master working and what we are planning on doing based off of that PTR
feedback for the launches season four.
And we've got a few updates.
Yeah, lots.
Yeah, sure.
So, I guess just starting off then with like high level itemization.
Like, let's go back to like some of the goals that we had.
And we start like down on this, start some of the work for season four.
Now, we want to make sure that first players were having an easier time
comparing items in their inventory.
Yeah.
It's actually one of the first things we started thinking about.
We began discussing what we thought needed to change about the itemization
because the experience in season three and season two and other seasons
has really been like the player, you know, you're getting to like the,
you know, you're running your high tier nightmare dungeons.
You're getting lots of drops.
You know, you're sorting through all of this stuff.
Like, you'll have like items that are like, you know,
this is like a 904 iPower sword.
This is a 909 iPower sword.
Now, I've got like six helmets at all or like a wide variety of
affixes on them.
We really wanted again just to quickly hit this.
We wanted to make sure that we had a lower number of affixes overall
that could roll on different item slots.
But those affixes were more like generically useful and stuff you could
really build around as opposed to having lots of really conditional affixes
going back to like the, you know, the damage on Tuesdays joke, you know,
like that's the shirt that the shirt that you want to run away.
Literally wearing it now.
It's always funny.
It's a huge proponent.
So it's obviously because it's a joke, right?
Oh, jokes are always funny.
But the truth is like we want to make sure that that the,
where we want to have conditional affixes in the game, we want to find
place players would be able to opt into them in a very specific way.
You know, so, so initially want items that you're either really dropping
for you to have more generic utility, just be just more valuable for
you overall.
And also as a result of this, make it easier to compare those items.
So one of the changes that we made is we actually reduced the number of affixes,
the affixes that can naturally roll on item slots.
So like now, like, you know, a rare item can roll like two affixes,
a legendary egg to roll three affixes.
But then later on, there's other systems you get to introduce,
you will talk about a bit, you'll actually introduce more of those.
Yeah.
And we did that.
So it's just easier to go through things.
We also made all items post level 195.
So you're no longer comparing like the designer number that's like 904 to 925.
You're just focusing on what's cool about the item, which is the affixes.
Yeah, which is super important because there's a lot of situations where like,
if you're, if you're level 100, like blood harvest might be a lot of fun,
but blood harvest is still dropping like 5 power, 900 items for you.
Yeah.
And at that point, what's the, why would you want to keep even blood harvest,
which players really love?
Like, why would you want to keep engaging with it if you can't get really good end game items for that?
Yeah.
So now when you're like at level 100 and you're playing in Helltide,
or if you're going through Nightmare Dungeons, like a regular, like a slightly lower tier,
and you're fighting, level 100 monsters are higher, you're always getting IPAR 925 items.
They might not have all exactly the stats or exactly the roles that you want,
but you're always getting stuff you could actually potentially use.
Yeah.
A lot of the things fill up better too, like gambling, right?
Like now gambling is actually a really great source for targeting items a lot,
because all of those are 925 at level 100.
That's right.
So like the Obel's you've been sitting on, where you go and you just churn through a whole bunch of these at once,
they didn't have as much generic value.
Now, there's, they're a lot better because you really can't just like say,
I am looking for a helmet.
I am looking for a ring, and you can just go roll, you know, 10 IPAR 925 rings in a row,
and you have stuff to play with at that point.
So yeah, those were some of the, like the high level changes you wanted to make with items,
with the garts, like making it easier to compare these things.
Codex, it's a lot like the, lovey, the inventory concerns,
we'd have made changes to gems in previous seasons,
so we didn't have as many of them clogging up your inventory as well.
So that was, we thought that was really, really good stuff.
But then we knew that we want to make sure that the,
that it wasn't just about, like, we weren't going to like add another tier of IPARPed items.
That wasn't the way to make itemization more interesting for players and rewards more interesting.
Now, one of the core things that we really wanted to focus around was the idea that, like,
like items have a journey, the best items have a journey, right?
So when you get a really good items about the, what the potential of that item is,
you know, what you can do with this item to make it really superior, right?
Yeah, definitely.
And that, that's sort of, to jump into tempering.
Yeah.
One of the first features we had in terms of taking your item on a journey was this idea that
we wanted hundreds of different affixes,
and each one spoke differently to a build.
We wanted you to be able to play sort of whatever class fantasy or build fantasy you had in mind,
and manifest that through customization of your items.
So we actually have some video, I think, of what the tempering feature looks like,
and I can talk through some of the updates we've made from the PTR.
So here you have, you know, we're adding an offensive affix to the item.
It's going to land on increased corpse explosion damage.
It's like, yeah, that's pretty cool, especially if you really like corpse explosion.
We've added a skip button, so you can skip through the flow if you really want to blast through this.
We also have a result screen now that shows you exactly what affix it landed on and what the roll range was.
And then we have some more exciting affixes that you're going to see here, for example,
chance to cast Bone Spear Projectile twice, which I know Adam is your favorite,
because I love the Balanced Bomb Drop.
I love that.
It is cool though, but you'll be able to...
Oh, there he is here.
So, yeah, we did our swap.
But Joe's not going to be here off screen.
We just want to make sure that Derek appears here.
Derek is our lead seasons designer, so he'll be talking a little bit more about Helltide Fliter.
Sorry to interject.
Okay, go ahead, Joe.
So, yeah, the snap off screen.
So, yeah, I think one of the really cool things about the tempering system in general
is that like the manuals that we're introducing initially are just like the beginning of what we can do with tempering.
It's actually just to make like really weird and interesting new affixes to kind of throw the player that we can introduce these in,
or another updates.
So, it's something that we can really extend and do some really neat stuff with.
Yeah, we absolutely plan to build a lot in the future.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Yeah, so a bunch of improvements to tempering overall.
Yeah.
And a lot of these...
Again, these improvements in tempering from the skip animations to the previews and stuff like that,
that players will see.
We're based off of feedback that we actually got from PTR.
Yeah.
And so, again, huge shout out to the community for providing all that feedback for us so that we can actually get that in before the launch of season 4.
So, but with tempering, we also have Masterworking, which is another new feature within season 4, and permanently within Diablo 4 itself.
So, talk us through a little bit about what Masterworking is, and of course the changes as well that we're going to be seeing based off of PTR feedback.
Sure, yeah.
So, you know, the next step in your items journey is to really take it to New Heights.
You've customized it.
You've found some base affixes you're really into.
And we want it to give you a way to essentially take some of these affixes to new levels.
So, you think about Helms and CDR or cooldown reduction, or for example, that chance to replicate your bone spear.
You want you to be able to really juice those stats.
So, I think we have a video here of what that looks like.
You know, overall, what we've really done is taken a look at the feedback.
We got a bunch of feedback that it was tedious to upgrade these over and over.
So, we've removed the animation from ranks 1 through 3.
We've kept the critical upgrade.
We have the animation still there, but you can skip it.
You know, again, sort of in the spirit of blasting across everything that we do.
So, we can do that very quickly.
And another piece of feedback that we got was that, you know, part of the Masterworking process allows you to reset this.
And why do you want to reset this? It's because you want to hit that specific affix or looking for you want to juice a specific affix.
And sometimes you might miss, right, which means you want to reset that item.
So, part of the resetting sort of requires you to get lower tier materials.
You're going to get these from the pivot. We'll talk about that a little bit later.
But overall, we saw a bunch of feedback that was really tedious to create like a thousand caches and open up them in town like a hundred times.
It's super annoying. The town is lava. We want to address that.
So, you know, we've added multiple scales of material conversion to those caches.
This is a short-term solution. We have something in the future planned. It's just not ready yet.
So, you know, while it's not the perfect solution, it does get you there a little bit quicker.
There's multiple conversion rates of materials. So, you can turn, you know, one legendary material into a much higher count of materials based on the tiers that we have in that crafting system.
Again, not the perfect solution. We have something coming in a future update.
Cool. Awesome. So, yeah, a lot of changes coming for master working based off of feedback.
Master working, of course, being a brand new kind of that entail of that item journey that you'll have even after tempering and stuff like that.
Yeah. I was saying another thing that was brought to Sphere was about veiled crystals, right?
Yeah. Didn't we lose the amount that you need for crafting?
We did. We did. And I can totally talk about some of the stuff we've done just overall on itemization.
Veiled crystals is one of those things.
Yeah. So, I'll talk about, first, I want to touch on rare and magic items.
That was something we made a change from season three and season four legendary items are just generally straight up better than rare items now.
And part of our goal there is really to ensure that players aren't sifting through sand, looking through thousands of items.
We want to just call it out, like legendary items or legendary.
At the same time, we acknowledge that there is some coolness to knowing that certain magic and rare items could have value to you.
We don't have anything for season four yet, but the design team is definitely talking about ways that we can bring this rarity back in a way that doesn't diminish our overall goal of trying to reduce that sort of sifting through sand.
So, in the meantime, they can be salvaged. They still have a use in the end game.
But we heard a ton of feedback to your point out on the Veiled crystals.
It's just such a bottle neck and it's like, God damn it, I have to pick a bunch of yellow items up.
Did you do any of the cool crafting features? What the hell was it?
That's an actual player quote too.
Yeah, I think they're very sure.
So, what we've done is we've made it so that legendaries break down into equal amounts of Veiled crystals.
So, you can just not pick up yellow items. It's just a bonus now.
We've also made sacred and ancestral items break down into two and three amounts of salvage.
So, sacred items will break down into double and sush roll will break down into triple.
So, we're effectively tripling the output of a lot of the salvage here.
And I know, so that one, that was probably the most vocal feedback that we got from players.
Maybe a little bit.
Yeah, but I need more Veiled crystals.
So, I know there's changes coming for that in season four based off that PTR feedback.
Another, probably maybe the second, maybe also the first one, topmost,
our largest feedback piece that we got is around greater affixes and visibility related to those.
So, there are changes going into that for season four.
So, Vaughan, do you want to talk a little bit about that?
Yeah, we want to, you know, the dopamine.
That was a big goal also of part of itemization is just like seeing an item hit the ground and just feeling like that jackpot moment.
Yeah, that's really important.
So, we actually have some video here to show of what that actually looks like on the ground.
So, you can see here's the weirdly long named items.
We're pretty good on this.
Yeah, right.
A yielding commander, sacrificial sickle.
I know, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So, we have a one greater affix star.
It'll go up to three or four if it's a unique item, which always feels incredible.
So, it shows up on the ground when it lands.
And then if we can go to the next video, we actually have an indicator now when it is in the inventory.
Yeah, so you can see it.
What is the difference?
It's a tree that's nice.
Right.
I was ever joke, and it looks so good.
I'm so happy.
I'm disappointed.
I can't see like the pixels.
It's not too great.
Yeah, so that's been enormously helpful.
And really, when you kill like Durel or one of these tormented bosses,
and they drop a ton of loot on the ground to see some of these have stars on them,
it just is a feel great moment.
Yeah, and it goes to what they're whole like not sitting through the sand.
You clearly see that icon.
You know that has value.
You know what that value looks like.
You know what that means.
Especially, again, even on the icon itself, like in your inventory, you will immediately know those are my greater.
Five Aphics items.
And Long gone are the days of the Roman numeral.
We already knew that.
Even like people who designed this really well.
It's funny.
I think internally we knew like, that's probably going to change.
We had a few jokes about that.
Sure.
I know one thing I want to touch on real quick before I move on the automation, if that's OK.
Yeah.
We actually, to touch on the build crystals, I think players are going to want to know this is
we reduce the imprinting cost of aspects quite a bit.
That's really going to help the build crystals as well.
I think it went from like 75 build crystals to imprint on an ancestral armor to 16.
Yeah, that's a pretty huge swing.
You're just getting way more of your aspects on here.
It's a lot more flexible.
So, that's it.
We really want people to feel like, you know, this is kind of the code of subpar updates in general,
which I'm really pumped about, is we want you to feel like you're able to reimprint those aspects.
Yeah.
It's something that you're not having a huge cost or a huge barrier to doing.
Right.
Because as you upgrade your gear, that should be part of your process is like putting on their favorite affixes.
Yeah.
So, a lot of changes coming with tempering, master working, itemization.
And I know, do we have any other changes that you wanted to cover before we move on to the next section?
And I've got this like this novel in front of me.
Yeah.
It was a key struggle.
Oh, one I would think is worth mentioning.
Calling me wants to talk about is the master working.
I remember we got a lot of feedback about the fail chance.
Oh, that's a great one.
Oh, yeah, this is one of the fail chance.
We took a lot of fun and fun and fun and that was like probably the biggest thing, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was the first bullet and I somehow missed it.
Yeah, yeah.
So, we definitely felt like there's a ton of feedback that the double random chance was just a little bit too much.
And we agreed, so we just took it out.
It's just fun now.
Just upgrade the item.
We adjusted the material costs a bit, but the fail chance is no longer there.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Cool.
So, we're going through those changes.
We'll actually be back to Colin here later because he still has more to talk about from his novel.
Yeah.
A paper study as he won the swap.
A paper pair.
But we did want to jump into some of the class balance changes that are coming after PTR, of course, with season four.
We have a lot of class balance changes that are on top of all these itemization changes.
And we got a lot of great feedback from players.
So, Mr. Adam Jackson.
You very much did.
Yes.
I love my slides.
We have got three categories of things that I'm going to be talking about today.
Again, thanks to everybody for playing on the PTR.
We did get a ton of feedback.
I'm not going to go over the specifics of everything that changed, but I'm going to go over kind of the categories of things just because there's a whole lot of changes.
One of the first big ones was end game survivability issues.
So, this is kind of talking about those people that went really far into the pit.
And this is kind of something that's been happening online as well that we want to address.
And there's this phenomenon when you get really deep into the game and you're fighting high level monsters where you know you'll hit a point where the monsters are kind of easy and you're able to blow through with your really powerful builds.
And then you kind of get to a point where they start one shot in you.
And it can be kind of mysterious and hard to understand like what's going on. Why did this happen?
We've also had some issues balancing that kind of top end survivability when you get to those hard monsters in the game.
One of the reasons for this is that variability in player defense of this has been really high traditionally.
This is why when you look at the new items in the game in season four, you don't see a damage reduction very much at all.
It's a very premium stat now that's really hard to get.
And it's to help solve this problem of when someone is stacking all damage reduction versus someone who has none of it, their difference in effective health and survivability is really, really high.
And so it makes it hard to balance the game.
Another part that we wanted to hit was really armor.
That armor is kind of a really confusing stat. It's not really well understood how it works.
I'm going to be going over it a little bit how it works and what we're changing to kind of adjust both of these issues a little bit.
Next is that some stats can get really high.
You know we added all these crazy awesome stats and you know you can juice them with master working and crit them and all these things.
And it allowed for some really crazy things on the PTR which people love to post constantly.
I mean and we to be clear we like crazy things you know it's it's awesome to get powerful and have that fantasy.
We do have to take into account things like combat clarity and computer performance to make sure that you know the game can still run very well for everybody.
So we made some changes there to adjust that.
You mean it's not fun to just not see your the screen.
I think it's for a little while.
It's hilarious I think.
It's funny for a bit but when you can always see like patches of ground.
And one player can do that let alone when you get four of them in a group.
And last but not least you know balance changes and bug fixes I'll be going over some of them but there's way more than what I'm covering right now today.
But just know like we took a lot of feedback on balance a lot of feedback on bugs.
There were a lot of them that were reported and we we acted on a lot of them and I'll give an example of something that we did.
All right so let's go into armor.
So brief history lesson or description how armor works today.
This is like when you log in how how armor is functioning makes your staff or physical damage mitigation.
So you know how you have your elemental resistance that caps at 75 and then can get pushed up a little bit.
Armor reduces your physical resistance up to a cap of 85% that can't go higher than that.
So that's the number. But what's confusing is the amount of armor that you need to get to that 85% cap is actually based on the level of the monster that you're fighting.
And I gave some examples here. This is these are the actual numbers in the game.
So if you have a level 50 monster that's hitting you you know whacking you then you need 5,265 armor and then you'll be out that 85% cap.
But then at level 100 and every level of you know like 51, 52, 53 is good.
That number is going up of what you need.
And at level 100 it's about you know 9,230 and then at level 150 monster it gets close to 13,000 right.
And so what this ends up you know kind of creating is that the player really never knows when they're done with armor right that that number can scale up forever.
It's kind of a hidden system under the hood. So when you're fighting these monsters and they get way higher level than you as you scale into the pit or nightmare dungeons or whatever.
You don't really know how much you need. And so this is kind of really contributing to that phenomenon where you're fine.
You're at the cap and then you aren't you know the higher level monster just start one shot in you.
So in season four, a lot of us can be the same as season three.
It's still going to be your source of physical damage mitigation. The cap is still going to be 85% and you're still going to need escalating amounts of armor as the monster level gets higher.
But what we're changing here if we go forward a little bit is that armor is now going to cap at that level 100 monster number.
So that 9,230 you can write down this number. We're also going to later get into the tool tip.
We couldn't get it in for the long season four, but we'll have it soon after.
But it's kind of going to be like elemental resistance where you get to this number and then you're kind of done with the system right.
So armor is just another thing on your check box of things you want to do as far as defensive survivability.
And once you get it, you're done. You know you can get it from gear, legendary aspects and so on.
Particularly in season four, I think this will be a little bit of an easy number to hit.
We're not trying to make this super difficult or hard to do. It'll be very achievable for you when you're a level 100 player.
So here we have a zoom in on the tool tips so you can see this player has you know way above that 9,000 amount of armor that they need.
You know they have close to 16,000, but you can see there, you know, it's capped out of that 85% physical resistance.
And again soon after the long season four, we're going to actually put the cap that you need of the number that you're chasing.
Because we want you to know what the goal is that you're trying to hit.
So means they have a lot of room for optimization.
Correct. Yeah.
This means that this player can actually give up armor on some of their tempering or item affixes and look for other stats.
Like that's kind of the point.
So next, the stat caps. So you know now that we've introduced a lot of ways to get really high amounts of stats in the game, we want to kind of control for visual clarity.
You know, what a player can put on to their screen.
So kind of somewhere to some caps we have already in the game like a tax speed or elemental resistance.
We're putting some caps on cooldown reduction and the increased area size.
You know like it's really fun to get those giant props known as that cover the screen.
But when it goes like two or three skirmies away, it can get really noisy and messy.
So we still want these stats to be really powerful and impactful.
But just control a little bit the amount of insanity that they can bring.
And one thing on this cooldown reduction cap to be clear, this is not just CDR across the entire game.
This is just capping what you can get from gear.
So this is like the base cooldown reduction you get when you first cast the skill what it's going to be.
You can still get cooldown resets or additional cooldown effects from things like the skill tree or legendary powers that just reduce the cooldown of your skills as you do certain mechanics.
This is just like the baseline cap that comes from your gear.
I think when we looked at the capper area effect too, we tested it on frost nova and we're like pretty meticulous on what that cap should be.
And it was still massive.
No, I see you.
But I'd say like a rake in a cap.
You're still going to get to insanity when it comes to what's on the screen.
It's still going to be awesome.
So you can see here this is just showing you what the tooltip looks like now.
So we're going to be showing you as a player what those caps are.
So you know when you're evaluating your gear on your tooltips, what it is.
And then same thing here you can see here like the dust a warrior effect size bonus it caps at 100%.
Next balance updates.
So again, like I mentioned before, we made a lot of balance changes based on feedback.
Again, thank you for playing and giving us all that feedback.
I'm going to go over some of the things.
One of the bigger categories of things was again, like I mentioned, those changes due to combat readability and balancing player power.
A few examples here of things that we're reducing are like the amount of dust doubles that can be on your screen.
And fractured winter glass.
One of my new favorite uniques we're bringing in the amount of frozen orbs that could span the screen is going to be reduced a bit.
So I want to prepare you all for that.
Again, to be clear, you're still going to spawn a whole lot.
It's just not going to be like insane amounts where you can't see things anymore.
They're still going to be very powerful. I'm going to show a video a little later of kind of the difference of PTR to what's going to ship in the game.
Some other things that we're doing fortify we wanted to increase the amount of damage reduction that you get.
This is just fortify across the board the base mechanic that DR is going from 10 to 15%.
And this was because before when it was at 10%, we had to take into account that players get damage reduction from a million different sources throughout the game.
Now that it's more and more premium, we can actually make this mechanic in the game a little bit more impactful and feel like you're a take your player for obvious into this.
These kinds of builds. We also made a lot of temporary naffix updates.
I'm not going to go as a detail them, just know like what you saw on PTR and what's going to shape your gets to get a lot of improvements, a lot of balance changes, even some shuffling around of the affixes to make them ways that make more sense based on feedback.
And then we did do some clash changes as well. I'm only going to give a very few examples here, but just know that there were quite a few.
One is jurid players. Companion jurid players always harass me. They want that build to work and I agree. It's really cool.
So we increased the health of jurid wolves by 200% and we also reduced the respawn rate and cut it in half.
So we got feedback basically that their companions were really good and fun and did damage, but in the late game they just kind of died and couldn't survive.
So we're doing this to kind of address that feedback.
Alright, so here's Dust Doubles as an example. You can see on the left, this is just one barbarian by themselves.
They came out of Dust Doubles and they could produce, right? And then on the right you can see kind of the same barbarian.
You can see like the Dust Doubles around the areas where the enemies are. They're still getting hit by a ton of them, but it's not covering the entire screen, right?
And especially when you get like three, four mini players together, it really becomes insanity.
Yeah, it's when you're in a party of four barbs or...
Yeah, it's just like everyone's a barb and I don't know where I'm walking.
Yeah, in other classes, we can do that kind of thing too, not just a barb, but this is kind of a good example.
So you know, this has kind of seen the difference between PTR and live.
And then next we have another class chain, so Scoundrel's Kiss.
This is another one of our new new Uniques that a row players give us a lot of feedback on.
So a quick summary of how this unique works is it kind of changes your rapid fire skill from shooting straight and hitting a single enemy into kind of a mortar skill where you shoot up into the air and then your arrows fall on the ground and explode.
It's really, really cool, but one of the pieces of feedback we got was that when you launched the arrows, they would kind of go and align and they wouldn't all hit the same enemy anymore.
So if you were trying to single target damage, it could actually be a nerf unless you like walked right up to the enemies and shot them.
And while there was a way to play around it, you know, players weren't really happy though.
Like we transformed the skill so much that I went from a range still skill to kind of a melee skill.
So we made an update here and we have a video of them before and after.
But basically see how the PTR on the left here, how you know, it goes in a big line and then the player has to run right next to the target dummy to do the full damage to it.
And on the right now, you'll see basically you target where those arrows are going to drop and they just all go to that area.
So you can hit a single enemy, but you also hit all the enemies around it because the arrows explode.
So she'd be a lot more usable compared to before.
Can Skendler's kiss ricochet with my rapid fire?
I'm pretty sure, yes, it can.
So it does all the things and it harrows all the things that your rapid fire does.
That's very cool.
But it's pretty cool.
Can a double projectile.
I'm pretty sure it can.
There's like everything else.
Yes.
Spam everywhere.
Yes, he loves spam.
And last but not least, a bug fixes.
Like I mentioned before, there were a whole lot of bug fixes reported to us.
Thank you all for getting them.
We address pretty much every single one that was reported.
I'm giving some examples here, but again, we got a lot more than what I'm showing on the screen.
One was Druid's Hurricane was incorrectly scaling damage, basically infinitely.
So we fixed that.
Evan Pierser, the extra missiles from our new unique.
They incorrectly had 100% lucky hit chance, which is procking a lot of crazy stuff.
And then Flame Weaver.
I don't know one of the new things we introduced to the game.
It's basically an effect where you can put a firewall on the ground and then you shoot fire bolts through it and you'll split the fire bolts.
Really cool fantasy.
But what happened with in the PTR was you could stack a bunch of fireballs right on top of each other.
And they would split the fire bolts multiplicatively and add more and more way more than intended.
So you could fire a ridiculous number of fireballs which were crashing servers and things.
So it wasn't great.
But now we fixed that so it'll work properly.
And again, you know, we're still discovering and working on other fixes.
There were a lot more that went in.
If you reported it, it was very likely fixed.
So basically the build will be in a much better stable state once we watch.
And that's really due to all your feedback.
So thanks again.
Awesome.
That's my section.
A lot of changes coming to classes, class balance feedback, where you got from PTR was really, really great.
Yeah.
We were able to make so many different changes there.
Of course, some of the biggest ones like the readability stuff that we probably saw.
I've seen the initial videos of like the dust doubles everywhere was, was, was, yeah.
It's crazy.
I was playing in a party with like, I was playing PTR and being in a party with like two, two barbs and like another like an echo master.
I was like, Oh, okay.
Everybody's going on the right to see it.
Yeah.
You know, PTR is, you know, one of the things you get to see things in development state.
I will say these kinds of things are actually pretty common when we're developing anything is being able to create these crazy situations.
And we, you know, we have the fix it for the game before it goes live.
So, you know, that's kind of the advantage of PTR's players can find these things.
Yeah.
Exactly.
So a lot more manpower being put in.
Yeah, PTR was super great for us to have.
Yeah.
Thanks again to the community for the feedback on all the class balance changes and thanks Adam for walking us through that.
The next thing we do want to talk about is with Derek over here.
Derek is actually going to talk a little bit about, of course, all the immense helltie changes.
Probably one of the most popular features and changes that we've introduced in season four with with PTR and people being able to experience it.
Of course, we got feedback based off of players jumping into helltie and we do want to go through all that with Derek.
And we also want to talk a little bit about the season itself with Derek.
So, Derek, want to jump in?
Yeah, just a few things to cover.
Yeah.
So, as you mentioned, the players who joined us when the PTR were caught all the various like blog and video posts and whatnot know that with season four were introducing permanent upgrades to the helltie experience.
Have you focused on improving and enhancing, I guess, monster density and activity variety?
There's a ton more things to do in the helltides and as a result, there's just a ton more monsters to, you know, know through in the helltides.
There's also some explorations and just to, you know, double back real quick, these are all permanent across both the seasonal and eternal realms.
So, they're not going away once season four ends.
This is just how it's part of the game.
Yeah.
Part of the game, kind of like our item updates too, right?
Yeah. Now, this is the game world we live in.
Yeah.
This is sanctuary.
But there's also, if you kind of look at the top rise screen, they're threat system.
So, the longer you're fighting in the tides, you're going to be accumulating threat which just results in even more monsters ambushing you at higher frequencies than monster packs.
I think the personal favorite and I think like fan favorite is the hellworm, you know, this giant demon slug bug that just pops out from the ground and just vomits monsters all over you.
You know, kind of with all those, the seasons as we say a lot are an amazing opportunity for experimentation.
And sometimes the best results of those experimentations are when they can inspire permanent upgrades and just enhancements to the base game as a whole.
So, that's where the hellborne and the new accursed ritual and blood made and come into play as part of the new helltide experience.
Yeah, look at those.
Those look great.
So, the hellborne and our season two players might recall, we introduced the blood seekers.
And those were really cool monsters based on class archetypes.
So, you're kind of like fighting the empiric shadow versions of yourself.
And we take a look at that content, we just love it from like the team perspective and just find like, hey, we're upgrading the helltides.
This is a perfect piece of content to just include with it.
So, that's where the hellborne came into play.
You know, they're fallen heroes of sanctuary.
They've been overtaken by the corruption from hell and kind of turned against you.
Kind of in line with that, the accursed ritual and the blood made in.
In season two with the bloodlers and the blood seekers, we introduced this concept of, I guess calling it just like, open world social boss summoning.
We followed up with like the, yeah, there's a buzzer right there.
Yeah, it's very, very, very casual.
Yeah, I love it.
Again, to my designer speak sometimes.
But yeah.
And we followed that up with like the mouth responders in season three.
And again, looking at these really successful experimentation from previous seasons, we love opportunities to bring players together and just add the extra outlayer to the helltide experience.
So, that's where the accursed ritual comes into play.
So, as you're out fighting gets the tides, you'll be collecting the new material, the painful hearts that you can bring to the accursed ritual.
It takes three to summon up the blood maiden and you can do this by yourself or you can partner up with some buddies and all, I guess, contribute to the summoning together.
And the blood maiden itself is our new helltide miniboss that she's immensely powerful but also very, very lucrative.
And I think the last thing a little forgot to mention is that this is all expanding into World Tour's one and two as well.
And kind of like a distilled not diluted.
So, the helltide and World Tour one and two is more specifically tuned to, I guess, like meet the leveling needs, the needs of the leveling player.
Awesome.
Well, on the blood maiden, I remember you had talked about with me before that the people that summon the blood maiden actually get bonus of the loot drops, right?
Yeah, absolutely.
So, you can either contribute just by yourself to the blood maiden and get some extra loot for your troubles.
Make sure that we give you a little bit extra because you're sacrificing up your hearts.
But also, every player that doesn't stack so you're not stressed to say, hey, I just need to be the one that summons them all.
We can all party up and just deposit our own bainful hearts and I guess reap the benefits of that.
Yeah, right.
To be clear, so if you put in all three, you get bonus loot, right?
Correct.
So, give me and Colin are in a group and like I put in two and you put in one, do I get more loot than you?
No, no.
So, you get the same amount of loot.
So, you know, if Colin has a bainful heart to deposit and if we all dump them in together, then we all get the share benefits of that.
Got it.
But I will touch on a bit later the PTR updates and just some of the enhanced value that the blood maiden received since PTR for both contributors and non-contributors to the summon.
Awesome. Yeah, so a lot of new stuff coming in for a hell-tight, then this is all part of the stuff that players got to experience in the PTR.
And of course, we got learnings from the PTR as you just mentioned.
Many.
Do you want to walk us through some of the changes that are coming in with hell-tight for all the PTR feedback that we had?
Yeah, I think I have a PowerPoint on my own.
Ooh, there you go.
You're gonna look at that.
Yeah, so as mentioned,
some of sweeping changes going into the hell-tides and just overall balance of the game in general season four.
And kind of with that, sometimes, you know, we push a little bit too far in some regard.
So, we did get feedback and also just own internal kind of fill checks on the center drop rates.
We're filling a bit slow in the PTR.
So, we just went back, reviewed it, and gathered our feedback and just iterated on the drop percentage to hit closer to the expectations of how much we want to be collecting the hell.
The senders and interacting with the tortured gifts.
So, I think we're in a much better spot right now actually.
So, that was one of the first major pieces coming out from the PTR.
A lot more chess from this, yeah.
Yeah, chess, more loot, more fun.
Awesome.
Let's see the next one.
Yeah, so on the topic of more is more fun, the Bainful Hearts.
We were noticing that they were dropping a bit inconsistently.
So, you can get the Bainful Hearts from opening tortured gifts, killing the hellborne, and one of the Doomseer variants, one of our new activity types.
But, again, we want to get the Bainful Hearts in the hands of the players with the pretty, you know, steady cadence.
So, we noticed with the PTR that we're just not gaining them as frequently as we wanted to.
So, we just went back, iterated, and kind of reviewed our bad luck protection to just ensure that we improved the consistency that Bainful Hearts are dropping.
And this is all kind of like, the Bloodmade is not meant to be seen as like this highly ambitious piece of content that you'll engage with like once every 50 levels.
We want you to get in the hearts, we want you engaging with the social boss summoning mechanic.
And, you know, I think it just adds that extra layer to the health as we want you to engage with.
And, on the topic of the Bloodmade in, overall like we touched on earlier, the Bloodmade into just seeing some overall rewards improvements.
So, as noticed, or as mentioned before, if you contribute to the summon of the Bloodmade in, you receive a bonus reward.
But, one of the things was that you couldn't really tell.
There is a little icon that appears like where your buff bar, but the effects about was largely unnoticed.
From both the team and actually know just the PTR players themselves.
So, again, taking this opportunity to just review the overall value of the Bloodmade for contributors and non-contributors alike.
Because again, we wanted to make sure that she has a clear role in the health had experience.
So, again, overall, Bloodmade is just overall more valuable.
For this, we're dropping things like legendaries for Gauten's Soul, Lorsair Mats, and a percent chance for contributors at the end-world tiers to get some end-game boss materials as well.
Yeah, so this is now an additional opportunity for players to get additional of the boss mats for the boss ladders.
Which, you know, we've heard a lot of how players were like, hey, we only really have one kind of method to get them and we wanted to expand that and bring that into more avenues.
Players didn't have to just kind of be like tunneled off into one area to get specific boss mats, which is cool.
Yeah, for ideas of the spice of life.
Yes.
I like that the contribution encourages these actually use these.
And see, I just chain some of the boss over and over and over and there would be this awkward dance where someone would shove and it's like, I know you have.
Yeah, that's why it's really also important that the nuance is honestly lost pretty frequently when we're talking about drops from different kinds of creatures and different types of stuff.
Like, treasure gobbling. We talked about treasure gobbling a while ago a few seasons ago and I remember I put a poll out on x.com.
So, at one point, I put a poll basically asking players what they believed the legendary drop rate of treasure gobbling to be and I had a whole bunch of options in there.
I think like 85% of the players were wrong.
Because the drop rate at that time was 50%. Players didn't feel it because they didn't see the treasure gobbling enough to really notice that it was actually that high.
So, I think making sure that we were like buffing up those moments where like if I had my contribution bonus and higher that helps make sure that is felt.
Yeah, absolutely.
You know what's funny is Joe talking off screen and we're all looking off and people are just staring us stare into this random corner.
You know what would be funny is to be all of those.
We're all just back there at a bail.
Every time. Every time.
And like Joe's turning into bail.
Oh, really coming in.
Oh, that's awkward.
I like the deep shadows that's where it is.
I guess the moment when I decide to say something maybe the old occasion.
Oh, we have another camera.
Awesome.
Cool.
So, a lot of health changes that we have coming into.
Yeah, I think there's actually one more slide.
So, one thing that we've kind of covered a lot across like just tempering and just the master working.
Just a spirit of season four in general.
Just like removing friction points and just keeping players in the flow of fun.
People want to blast.
Yeah, absolutely.
So, one of the doomsayer variants.
And again, like the doomsayer's new activity type is kind of a kind of a kind of a surprise where you interact with them.
They crackle and pop into something of a variety of things actually.
So, one of the variants that we had was the chest of doomsaying where they would explode into a tortured gift that costs 50%.
And gives you a whole lot of good stuff.
We're kind of reviewing that.
And sometimes what could happen is you can encounter one of these at the very start of your health tide run.
You don't have 50 centers.
It's not a lot to get, but it still is kind of a stressful potentially fills bad moment.
So, we just said, hey, let's just have it explode into the loot directly.
You say 50 centers and you kind of just keep going on your merry way in the tides.
So, that's one of the kind of like efficiency smoothing out that we've done.
The next one is also just, we're dumping a whole bunch of monsters on you.
And it's always a filled bad moment when you get knocked out of interaction.
You're trying just to open up the tortured gift and you know, head out.
So, we reduced the channel time to open tortured gifts from three seconds to 1.5 seconds.
I believe for season four launch proper.
Thanks.
That'll help a lot.
So, and I think while I just some feedback are like, you know, why don't we just make it instant, right?
Right. Right. Right. Yeah, you know, we kind of do want a safeguard against like the accidental clicks.
Again, it's a frenetic game. So, you're clicking a whole bunch and, you know, I think 1.5 seconds is enough time to, you know, let you make sure that that's what you want to commit to before you open it.
And there's also like, because you guys can talk about this, there's changes to like the channeling.
Like you, I think with like dot damage and stuff like that.
Yeah, yeah, dot damage now will interrupt channeling as well.
Yeah. Which is pretty nice.
Which is good. So, especially as you are in the frantic areas of hell tide and everything.
So, yeah, lots of hell tide changes, a lot of good feedback from players from PTR.
Derek, thanks for walking through on that.
But you're not done yet. But we do want to do more.
Yeah, but wait a minute.
As you guys know, like there is this is season four, we're born and part of hell tide includes the iron walls.
And some people have figured that out even before our blog on Tuesday.
But we did want to talk a little bit about season four and iron walls participation in that,
along with some cool things that are specific to seasonal characters for season four as well.
Yeah, yeah. So again, as mentioned, the players who joined us in the PTR or again caught all the various blog posts will notice that the iron wolves are now a permanent part of the hell tides.
You know, they're fighting and dying alongside the players now and they're here to stay.
However, for our seasonal players, we have the call of the wolf seasonal activity,
where players will get to spend a bit more time with the iron wolves and go on a bit of a journey with them to try and uncover the potential root cause behind these rising tides and uncover this mysterious phenomenon that's threatening to corrupt and consume the iron wolves from within.
But in addition to that, you know, again, the iron wolves are in the hell tides with you.
As players are fighting and dying alongside the iron wolves and the hell tides, you're also going to be earning your way through the wolves honor reputation system.
And this is saying you progress your way through a collection of just super juiced rewards that are specifically turned to overpower your leveling journey from level one to 100 and beyond.
The main pillar for this reputation track was really pushing the players powers forward, the player power for the players power forward and giving them early access to, you know, gear with the juice stats, legendaries, materials, boss materials and even a resplendent spark to as like a cherry on top at the end.
We love the juice.
We do, you do love that.
But, you know, in the spirit of weight, there's more, you know, those are all like the gameplay related things, but we also have a couple really cool cosmetics that you earn through the collective call the wolf season activity.
So this is the iron wolf mount trophy, the little iron wolf banner and oh, a little bit fast, but yeah, so the iron wolf mount trophy, we're doing a lifer.
That's earned from completing the rep, there it is.
You can get both of them.
That's earned through completing the reputation track and the blood made in head is earned by completing the associated iron, the call the wolf quest line.
Awesome. Yeah, those look really great. And of course, as you mentioned, resplendent sparks.
And then I know there's one other item that I know we wanted to talk about with this season specific because it is specific for season four and yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thanks for the reminder of that. There's so much to cover.
There's a lot. Derek has like the largest list of items to kind of go through here. So, yeah, so you know, as mentioned before, on the seasonal team, we love our experiments.
And I don't think a season will be one without some of the little experiments. So with that, we have the seasonal item, whereas kind of like call it the seasonal toy.
And that's the profane mine cage.
Yep, so there it is. So the profane mine cage is pretty cool in the sense that it's a guaranteed drop from the hellborn.
And when you consume it, I kind of like to imagine you just like eating this demon brain.
Yeah.
When you consume it, for the next 60 minutes, the haltyd monsters are going to be boosted up to 10 levels, depending on the world tour that you consume it in.
And you're also going to be increasing their aberrant, sender dropper rates. So, you know, again, all tying this back to that leveling journey and like tempering and stuff.
Like this is a really fun item that lets you kind of put your build to a little bit more of a test in exchange for maximizing your haltyd efficiencies through, you know, just one higher months level means more XP and some like that.
And also just aberrant sender drops too.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, go ahead.
I was going to say we'd use the world tour to three and four XP.
So that's super well.
So you can just get to Blasta and get very quickly now.
Yeah. And with the my page itself, like, you know, because everyone's probably going like, well, that's a consumable, like how do how do people end up like obtaining additional ones of those or can get more of those throughout the season and everything?
Yeah, we want to be very generous with those.
So one, they're a guaranteed drop from the hellborn in world tours three and four.
But you can also use them in world tours one and two.
So if you want to like boost some level, you know, all in what not.
And you can also get a, I think like a bucket of them through the Wolves honor reputation.
Like we crammed as many rewards as we could in there.
So they will be in steady stream.
So don't again in the spirit of like use it.
Don't hoard it.
Definitely experiment and have fun with this thing because you know, it's a game. Have fun.
Yeah. So it's great.
Like if you want a little bit more of a challenge, a little bit better rewards as well.
You can of course use your your mind cage.
And that is exclusive for players in the season.
Yeah, it's awesome to see.
But yeah, thank you, Derek, for walking through all the changes with Helltide.
Of course, it's some of the new season stuff with the Ironwolves.
And if you're a lore nerd, Ironwolves of course are very familiar faction within Diablo.
They are from Diablo 2, act three.
You could actually hire them as some of your mercenaries there.
One of the mercenary options though we know a lot of people on with an act two mercenary in Diablo 2 for the aura.
But yes, cool.
Thank you so much.
Derek, of course we still have more to talk about.
We're actually going to go back to Colin.
And Colin is going to talk us through a little bit about the pit.
The pit is a brand new feature within season four.
And it's out a permanent feature within Diablo 4.
And yeah, do you want to like give us a breakdown from people who may have not experienced the pit or may have not seen the stream beforehand.
And then on top of that, tell us about all the improvements that we're doing to the pit based off of people.
Yeah, so you know something that players have asked for since we did a bunch of nerfs to the nightmare dungeons.
If you recall, I forgot what season it was, but we made tier 100 nightmare dungeons a lot easier.
So players can get through them.
One of the big pieces of feedback we got was, okay, well where's my measuring stick?
You know, the game is a power fantasy. It's about getting as much raw power as possible and just dominating.
So if there's no place to push back, then everything is just a little bit too easy.
So the pit of the artificer is our answer to that measuring stick.
You're going to be able to push very deep into the pit.
There's a lot of levels. We were inspired by Abitware of Zero.
But to be very clear, you know, Abitware of Zero was a special case and that each tier jump was just like brutal.
It was like ridiculously hard.
Every single tier and it's like, you can only get to 7, which isn't very heroic or powerful.
So we've taken a lot of the learnings from Abitware of Zero.
The pit goes very deep. There's many more tiers.
It's much more gradual. So you can start pushing into it and getting some of these master working material rewards.
And the pit is all about, you know, just blasting through monsters and the demons of hell, right?
There's no negative modifiers. We're not CCing you a bunch.
You know, this is really just a test of how powerful your build is.
So from the PTR, we actually got feedback that it was way too easy because we added a ton of power through tempering,
through the codecs of powers, just much easier to get a lot of those aspects online.
So we've taken a look and we've moved some of the master working material tiers around previously.
You know, the tier one master working materials only came from 1 to 20.
We've moved that up 10 tiers. So tier one will come from 1 to 29.
Tier two will come from 30 to 59 and tier three will be 60 plus.
And what that does, it just makes the journey feel a little bit more rewarding, right?
Like we saw in the PTR that people just like within the first two hours just blasted through all of it because they're so powerful.
So we've just adjusted some of the rates there.
So you have to push a little bit deeper. You have to optimize your build a little bit more.
So those armor caps are things to watch out for, right?
If you're over the armor cap, it's just a straight optimization to start thinking about how you want to replace them in the armor.
And we think that feels pretty good.
And overall, we've increased the health and damage, or sorry, I should say increased the health on all monsters post level 100 both in the pit and nightmare dungeons.
So the enemy should be pushing back on you a little bit more, right?
You care a little bit more about utility, defense outside of just one shot and everything, right?
So it sort of tests you a lot more.
And part of that feedback though that we've heard is that well, nightmare dungeons don't feel very rewarding.
The pit doesn't feel super rewarding post, you know, that 62 when you're getting those master working top end master working materials.
So we've done two major changes.
One is we've added obols that scale with both of these tiers.
So everything passed tier 46 nightmare dungeons and everything passed tier one.
And the pit actually, it always gives you obols.
You might ask like, but obols are terrible.
But again, I want obols, call it.
I know, right. A big part of season four was that we made the gambler guarantee 925 legendaries at level 100.
And those legendaries can roll greater apics.
So if you blow a ton of obols on two handers, for example, those two handed legendaries are getting are the same as anywhere else in the game.
So it's actually a huge efficiency boost to getting items you're looking for.
So you can get like some of the best items.
You can get the obel that are now absolutely.
And one thing that is also changing with obols is like, because you know, when people pick up obols, they're like,
I've got my cap.
And now I'm like, oh my god, I'm back down.
But call in the obelcap is fun.
So, you know, like, we've increased the obelcap substantially.
So the amount of obols you get now is 2500.
You can hold that.
So you can just like, go to the gambler and give me everything.
And you can just do that a couple of times.
So get your obels and hit the tables for your game.
Yeah, exactly.
And the items are incredible.
And just to like, double down this for a second too, like the, like, one of the things that we also did as part of this, like when you're,
when you use the enchanting feature in Diablo IV, you can't actually enchant off of an apics into a greater apics.
So when a good item drops for you in the base game, you can't, you can't try to like, roll for greater apics who's off the enchanting system.
It's good for getting you to a stat you really need in a situation where an item didn't get you what you wanted.
But now with the obel's vendor, like those items, not only are they IPAR 925 and they have the chance to be legendary, of course, like the obel's vendor always has.
But you also have a chance to get greater apics who's off those game.
Yeah.
So if you are again, if you're looking for a particular pair of gloves, you're looking for a particular helmet, and you're really, you're saying I really want a greater apics version of cool down reduction on my helmet.
Right.
Now it's like, okay, cool, I'm going to take my 2000 obel's, I'm going to go to the, I'm going to go to the vendor, I'm just going to just gamble gamble gamble and try to get the try to get that one helmet.
Like now I have a chance to really do that. And this is a way for you to like getting more drops and such inside the pit is one thing, but giving you more choice when you get out of a pit run, I think you're very, very valuable.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, and another change we made was to glyph XB. We got a bunch of feedbacks. It's like, yeah, what the hell, nightmare dungeon. So we've increased the glyph XB by 25%, which is faster and leveling.
And we've also scaled the amount of rune shards, which is the pit currency to get into the pit with nightmare dungeon.
So you can create sort of a positive feedback loop if you're really strong and you're really powerful, you're hitting those tier 100s and the nightmare dungeons are getting tons of pit keys that you can then translate into the pit and just get lots of runs and lots of mass working there.
Yeah, so a lot of feedback from nightmare dungeons, people were saying like, hey, are we planning on making any changes to that glyph XB?
Yeah, so there are sure that we actioned on it.
Sure. And there's funny enough, there's also even in the season journey, I believe there's also like changes to that, the hashes themselves where you can actually use that to boost even like glyph XB is also part of that with the season journey.
So, very cool. So, we have one more. Sorry.
I have this list, but then I don't actually.
But then she's like a pro.
One other thing that we did was we heard a bunch of feedback that players were dying at the end of the pit because we have this like shadow boss that sometimes comes in and throws a wrench in what you're doing.
And you know, as much as I push for learn to play, you know, our encounter design is absolutely.
Take this for players.
Surprise.
Yeah, isn't it fun to die after you killed the boss?
Yeah, so our encounter designer did an amazing job.
And I think a lot of those affixes after you killed that boss and the arena should be clear now.
As Chats says, get good.
But yeah, we saw that a lot and if you're a hardcore player that would have been a tragic lost character.
I prefer the world of hilarious.
Yeah, some designers like this pumping like you.
Yeah, just watching streams and reactions from that.
So a lot of changes coming for the pit is of course a new feature within Diablo 4 permanently.
And you can experience that in eternal and seasonal realms.
And of course, we have some updates to the boss ladder because the boss ladder itself is changing pretty, pretty significantly.
We talked a little bit about like how you can get additional materials and other places that Derek had mentioned.
But Colin has additional points that he wants to bring up about the boss ladder because we got a lot of feedback on that.
And there's some new changes to it in season four.
Yeah, so we added Endario the best lesser evil.
Yes.
Boo asma Derek.
Yeah, he's dunking me.
That's dunks me with a warped old day who likes that guy.
So Endario obviously has come back.
She's incredibly fun to fight.
They counter design team killed it.
And you know, on top of Endario, we've added a new tier to the boss ladder called tormented bosses.
So these are much higher level level 200 bosses.
Sort of pinnacle aspirational bosses to take down.
And what we've done here is we heard a bunch of feedback that it required five times the amount of boss materials, including some rare pit material to summon these.
And five times the reward.
That didn't really feel like the right amount of reward efficiency for taking on something that was challenging.
So we've nerfed the cost.
It's now three X the amount of boss material and five X the rewards.
You get some pretty big efficiency wins there, especially if you're crushing them and then game.
So that's feeling pretty good.
We think we also heard a lot of feedback that it's tedious to do the same activity over and over and over to summon some of these things.
So it's like I want to summon pendant at night or I want to do the beast and ice.
I know you and I have done that one.
Yeah, 100 dill at chosen in the season requires the beast and ice.
And it's like I guess I'm stuck in the number of dungeon.
I'm not going to tell her or it's great.
Yeah, yeah.
So yeah, well, we made it better.
A lot of our random monsters and activities and things like that.
So elites, whisper caches, treasure goblins, world bosses, hell born to name a few.
We're all going to start randomly dropping these boss materials.
So you know, you're not necessarily forced into doing one exact activity.
It's still going to be the absolute best way to get some of this boss material.
But as long as you're blasting, you're just going to be getting a lot of these materials ambiently, which you can trade.
You can just sort of cash in on your heart's desire.
And we think this makes the game feel more flexible and sort of enables you to play a little bit more on how you want to play.
I'll still keep the experience fresh.
So we think that's going to be a pretty big win.
Yeah, huge.
Yeah.
To jump back into the torment bosses, I just, because I'm going to jump around a little bit.
We heard a bunch of feedback, especially from Medijo.
Hopefully he's watching is there's a lot of way we're just watching around.
I know, probably not.
It's not very interesting.
We did some tuning to make sure that the torment and versions have some more parody, right?
It was sort of like an, in a scenario where like one of the latter bosses was just like dead easy.
Didn't really match the difficulty of the rest.
And that's important because we give you one guaranteed respondent spark one time for defeating any of these.
So one step closer to getting that Uber unique that's not just a rod drop of your choice, which is pretty awesome.
And then something else, you know, speaking of respondent sparks, we're adding one to Uber Lilith.
So the first time you kill Uber Lilith, you're also going to get another respondent spark.
So now that brings us to three opportunities of being able to earn yourself a respondent spark.
That's where you heard one from Derek at the end of the season, the Iron Moles board, and doing that within the season.
We now have one with the echo of Lilith, and of course one with your first tormented boss as well.
So additional opportunities to earn respondent spark.
And of course you can still salvage your any Uber gear that you do happen to find.
And you can actually earn a respondent spark.
So what I mean is if you do all these and then you get an Uber unique, you can actually change that into whatever one you want.
Yes.
Yeah. This is where the Lilith that means.
And then something else, you know, on the Uber Uniques is the, I'm just laughing because I didn't realize this, but chat's calling out.
Our tool tip that we showed, we had 200 plus respondent spark.
Yeah. That's what happens when you're working.
We're just really happy.
Yeah.
That's how I get them.
Let me tell you guys, you get them tools.
Yeah.
Okay. That's actually my account online.
Oh yeah.
Nice.
So on the Uber Uniques, you know, we heard a bunch of feedback that it feels like a chore to have to do, you know,
the penitent and I into Varshawn into doing Durel just for a chance at an Uber Unique, right?
And, you know, we've experienced that ourselves, right?
It's like, God, I gotta do all this stuff to fight the boss that's gonna actually drop something that I care about.
You know, greater affix is help that because, you know, there's some variation to the Uniques you're gonna get.
But for Uber Uniques, we've actually added a small chance, a little bit lower than Durel to all of the ladder bosses.
And they're gonna have a chance to drop an Uber Unique as well.
So, you know, while you're grinding through this ladder, every single boss you kill is gonna have a chance to drop an Uber Unique.
It's not exactly the same as Durel, Durel and Durel.
We should do like a combo or a Durel or a lot of rails.
And we think that's gonna make it feel a lot better.
Awesome.
So yeah, a lot of changes coming with the boss ladder and changes based off of PTR feedback that we saw.
Well, that's just overall changes for season four that we were planning.
So that it gives more opportunities for players to actually experience it.
Of course, the new versions of the bosses and sells and are more than that co-version.
So, awesome.
Thank you so much, Colin.
Of course.
And I know we wanted to, before we jump into Q&A because we were getting towards the end of our updates for season four,
Mr. Adam Jackson wants to talk a little bit about the season journey.
This is actually something really cool.
One last thing.
It's over on Class Designer.
We're really passionate about this and we're excited for it.
So the season journey.
So we really want to kind of use the rewards and make the season journey more exciting.
And so what we went and did was when you're going through the season journey for every class,
you're actually going to be getting a preset curated amount of legendaries as you're going through
that are targeted toward a specific build.
So we chose a build for every class in season four and we're gonna change it around in future seasons.
Please give us feedback on this but we think it'll be pretty cool.
But you're basically going to get like close to a completed build when it comes to opening those caches.
They're guaranteed targeted legendaries to build a specific fantasy for every class.
I think we have a video to show what they're going to be for every class in season four.
Maybe there.
So Barbarian here, you can see we're gonna be giving you a bunch of legendaries related to dust doubles.
The Druid, we're gonna be giving you basically a pulverized build, which is pretty cool.
Next is the Necromancer.
Of course, everybody's gonna be playing minions.
So we gave you a bunch of minion focused legendaries.
It should be pretty awesome.
And then next is the Sorceress.
We actually have a cool new legendary coming into the game for incinerate, which you'll see here.
It's very tough.
So we were giving you an incinerate build on the Sorceress.
And then the Rogue, we're giving you one target toward Barrage.
So again, kind of the point of this is that if you don't really know what you want to play,
or you really want to just go through a season journey and try out something before you go to a build that you really want to do,
you have a foundation of something more complete to start with, which we're pretty excited about.
Yeah, and with the Codex change now, you also get to kill all those items that are actually dropping out of the season journey caches.
You get to keep those.
They're all going to your codex.
You can use that build to the entire year leveling process.
Correct.
Yeah.
Awesome.
So lots of changes coming in season.
Sorry, my mic died half way through there.
So I did do a quick mic swap as we were playing it.
We were free, too.
Also Joe Pyfors back.
Hi, Joe.
Derek is now over here.
So if people are confused of like what's going on, we are playing musical chairs.
And that is also a new feature.
Our favorite season for it.
I'm just kidding.
But yeah, so a lot of changes season for.
Previewage is by far the biggest season for Diablo IV yet.
And I know we wanted to jump into Q&A.
I do want to bring up one thing as well.
Oh, wow.
Which is this is a change that will be represented.
And by the way, patch notes are coming out immediately after this stream.
So.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
So that's one thing.
So yeah, people can check out patch notes immediately after this stream.
Please enjoy reading it as much as we enjoyed writing it.
Previewing it.
And I wouldn't, based off of the size of the patch notes, I wouldn't be surprised if we do have a few things that might be missing.
That would probably like have to post ad if as we're kind of going through it just because it's massive in terms of size as people saw from PTR.
And now it's just even.
There were a lot of different teams.
I'll like effort trying to do this to you.
Yeah, so.
But patch notes will be up.
One thing in the patch notes that I did want to bring up is, and this is a thing that's coming in season four is for players that want to change their their hair on their characters themselves.
They can actually go to the wardrobe now and actually be able to do it, which is a nice, like, good quality of life feature.
We've heard a lot of people go like, hey, I kind of want to, you know, I made that character a while ago, especially like an internal character or something like that.
I would like to be able to change that around.
Yeah, now that flexibility being able to do so, which is actually really cool.
So.
We're going to jump into Q and A as usual as we always do.
Yeah.
We will start off with a question.
This is actually something that's been a popular topic that a lot of people have been talking about since PTR.
And of course, even this week with the blog itself, but.
Don't we mean suspense?
I know.
I think there's the question.
There it is.
What does this mean for season powers in the future?
Oh, just what season four is?
Like the nature of season four?
Yeah, okay.
Sure.
So, yeah, season four is a season four, as I mentioned before, is like an opportunity for us to kind of like lift up a lot of aspects of the game that we think are really important.
Diablo is a game about killing monsters and getting loot.
And as I said before, getting loot, we need to make sure it feels at least as good as killing monsters.
Right?
It's extremely important that this part feels good.
And we took a lot of our development effort and put it against that goal as part of this release.
And there were other parts to gain what we lifted up at the same time.
Like the various changes that we talked about for Helltide, for example, you know, the Meary New Tempering recipes and things like that.
There's lots of things we did, I think as part of the release, just make the base experience of Diablo four more fun.
Right?
So, I'm really excited to be able to do that in season four.
Thinking about what the future holds, we always want to make sure that with every season, you know, we are adapting to what we think the game needs at that time.
We think it's going to make for a better experience overall.
We love the idea of seasonal powers.
We've learned a lot of really, really great stuff from the days of the barber, all the way through the vampire powers we got in season two,
and all the sentatial and constant stuff we had in season three.
We have lots of big ideas for the future, so you will see seasonal powers again in future in different themes and mechanics as we go.
That's kind of our promise to you.
And with the things we have in terms of the Iron Wolf's quest line and the various rewards you get,
change to the seed and journey for getting all of those themed items, those various aspect builds together as you kind of progress through.
We want to keep building up on these mechanical elements as well at the same time, to help lift up the experience.
So yeah, we will be returning to seasonal powers in the future.
But with every season, we want to make sure that we're doing what we think is uplifting the game up the most, the things that we think are most important at that time.
Awesome.
A question from our... I'll bounce between some questions from chat and from our forums, because we did have a thread up in our forums about specific questions.
This one's from the forums, this is from Abelon.
They're asking if, because season three actually ran longer and season four itself had a PTR, will season four actually be a shortened season or will it still be a standard size season?
They weren't sure how PTR is actually affecting the time on it.
So PTR is not as impactful from the timing here.
I think it's a slightly shorter season. I think it's like one week shorter or something.
I think it's a look at the date.
Yeah, and I will note, the reason why season three ran longer was because we wanted to make sure that we could get that PTR.
This was our first PTR, so there's a little bit more effort needed to get that out for pull-ups.
I guess you're absolutely right.
So when I think about the future and what PTR is look like, we want things to be...
It's not that having a PTR automatically means that everything is going to take longer to deliver.
But there's a lot of things we had to set up at the first time for the PTR for season four.
I'm really glad that we did, because as I think you've seen, there's a lot of things we learned going through the process.
Give us a time to iterate and use the feedback to which we did a lot of things on.
Question from Blake Darko's CS.
Will you guys think about maybe a potential different being color for items with greater affixes?
So I don't be talked about this for a while.
Yeah, I think that's something we're definitely going to keep an eye on.
Right now we think that the little dots, I should say huge dots, the huge stars on them, are doing a pretty good job.
But that's something that we also need to feel out and play and we're super open to feedback and seeing how these new big stars are going to help.
Yeah.
Especially the changes in the inventory, because now you can actually identify them in your inventory and everything is really big.
We also roll on unique, so there's a little bit of work that we'll need to figure out.
Yeah, it's true.
Yeah, you can get greater affix on your new colors as well.
Yeah, so the beam color gets a little confusing there.
So something that we've seen from players and a lot of people bringing that specifically up.
Fire Dragon Dad says, this season four update is going to retro into existing eternal.
So, see, everything we talked about today with the exception of the Iron Wolf's quest line stuff, it isn't actually present in the eternal realm.
So, players like the Codex Power Changes, everything like that will be there.
I know there are a lot of questions related to the Codex Changes, especially for eternal players.
And just to clarify, if you have aspects in your inventory and your stash, it'll take whatever your highest roll of that specific aspect.
And that will become your new best Codex entry when season four does start.
You may need to log on to specific characters on the eternal to at least, like, for us to be able to check your inventory.
But the stash, I know, will automatically move over there.
And same thing for, I know we get a lot of questions about items on the eternal.
Those will be marked as like legacy items specifically, because obviously we've changed a lot about that.
And those items, you can't craft on those items either at this point.
You can't temper those items, you can't masterwork those items.
But they'll still retain like the item upgrade state that they have in the Blacksmith.
Exactly.
So, if it doesn't mean like when you log on all your gear is suddenly unusable, it's just marked as legacy and you won't be able to use tempering on that.
It's a great stepping off point to getting some new items that could have greater affixes and other things that could be making it even more powerful.
A question that we have actually from the forums, this is from Iggy.
With the itemization rework, is there what is like the next like big thing you guys are actually looking at potentially wanting to really work on within the team?
I don't know if we want to play our cards too early on.
Yeah.
I think it's working on things.
We're working on all kinds of stuff, everybody.
But no, I think one thing we want to continue to work on, I think you see like as we're thinking more about the end game experience, a lot like when we launched the Apollo 4, we thought of end game really as a journey from like really from 50 to 100, like the things you're doing along the way and getting all of your prepare on the lips and leveling those glyphs up and going deeper in the nightmare dungeons and you know going eventually confronting low.
That was what we kind of imagined or thought that the end game would feel like and that was a good thing for us to build on.
I think we saw that a lot more players were looking for end game like explicitly at level 100.
That was when they wanted a lot more things to open up and we made a lot of changes recently to try to like create more gameplay around that part of the experience between like the itemization changes and the crafting changes and also the introduction of like tormented bosses and of course the piviar officer.
Yeah.
So I think that like we know that there's more opportunities for us to build on these things, right?
I think you've heard me say this before but you know a lot of things we're doing in season four specifically really are done to like build a new framework, you know for how end game sort of functions.
The things that drive a player for the things that get them excited and the content that they engage with along the way as well, right?
We want to make sure that they're having that players are having a really fun time or a warning time while they're playing Diablo 4 and they can find opportunities to be appropriately challenged as they go through the experience as well.
We think there's more opportunities for us to kind of like grow and expand the offerings of things that players have access to the things they can go experience.
You know at that stage of the game.
Awesome question from old dudes new games and I love these names. They're so good.
What about codex resetting when swapping characters that was actually just an issue on PTR like when you when you swapped characters and stuff like that.
Yeah, when you use the boost NPC.
Yeah, so that that was not a thing that you will experience in season four.
And so that's not a common thing or a normal thing that's supposed to actually happen.
I just was a bug that we had in PTR.
There's a lot of questions here about the mind cage and I just want to maybe clarify with the players.
Opus Crocus says if you consume more than one does the mind cage stack or does the timer reset.
Time reset I think.
The timer reset timer reset.
Okay, and then in regards to again this is from optics.
Do K or do mind cages trigger for a single player or your whole group if you're grouped up.
Single player.
Just a single player.
Yeah, it's a personal thing.
Okay, all right.
So clarity around the mind cage is in it.
We've had a lot of people ask specifically about that.
And we want a feedback on this by the way too.
So when you get chance to play with the mind cage during the season like you know,
tell us what you think.
Want to know.
This is from new poo games.
Do unique items get a stat slash functionality boost since tempered legendaries are just straight up better.
And is it generally not worth it to equip a unique item after the patch?
Yeah, I mean, I think Adam can speak to some of these changes if you wanted to jump in.
But we've done a pass on all the unique items.
We've done things like razor plate because four thorns apics is and we change what the legendary power is.
Yeah, by the way, that was a big question we got from people of the PTR because they're like,
Hey, what about razor plate?
We heard a lot.
In that patch, razor plate.
Yeah, it's actually in the patch notes.
And yeah, it's a lot of thorns.
Razor plate is blarious.
It's a whole way.
I wanted to just have like one so you can't miss on master work.
Yeah, but what I'll say about the unique to legendary item power level, I suppose, is that we knew when we were making these tempering changes and updating those that we wanted
legendaries because they kind of have a jerk like they have kind of different identities right now in the game.
And so we're still figuring out what we wanted with unique long term.
But the idea is that like legendary items or items really they have a journey and you know, you're working on them and there's a story to them.
And you know, you get it.
It's not like a one stop shop.
You're done kind of like how they were before.
Unique.
So part of our identity is that that I get them.
You get a unique and it's freaking awesome.
Really powerful and very exciting and you have it and you're done with it.
And so we're keeping this discrepancy of like what their purposes are in the game for now.
And kind of seeing how it goes.
We did take a look at some Uniques, but we didn't like do a whole pass of like, you know, every single unique now has five outfits or something like that.
Like we wanted them to be a little bit different and different identities.
So we do kind of expect that Uniques may be less prevalent than they were before.
We still believe though that a lot of Uniques are really key for various builds.
And so you're still going to want them, but you're not going to want like a unique and every single slot on your character now.
Because it's clearly always better, right?
Sometimes some of those will want more Uniques, some will want less.
And we want to kind of see how that plays first before making sweeping changes.
You know, some obvious rows we could take is like adding crafting to Uniques.
What if you could temper them?
What if you could do these other things, right?
We know that that's a thing and we may do that in the future, but we're kind of evaluating this world where it's not clearly always you only get one or the other.
And we kind of want to see how that goes first before making any big changes.
Yeah. And the fixed nature sort of has you consider it's part of your optimization puzzle.
Well, I'm going to give up some tempering affixes to get this unique, for example, in my chess slot, for example.
We sort of want to see where that goes. Like we think that that's that's fun.
And we think that the excitement of a unique is those are those fixed stats.
When you see the item on the ground, you know, like, okay, that's that's the unique.
I can just equip it. I don't even have to work on it.
Yeah, it's just like there for me.
So awesome.
And then I know by the way, did we talk about a master working or not mass working?
We did talk a lot of talk.
We've done it twice on two.
Did we talk about groups and I with the pit?
I didn't write it down and I didn't talk about it.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So we got a bunch of feedback that, you know, it sucks to help someone with their pit run and just not get any master working materials.
Like, well, why am I here?
So what we've done is we've made it so that the person who opens the pit is going to get a hundred percent of the master working materials.
Previously, I think it was split maybe across all players.
And what we've done now is that the person who opens it gets a hundred percent and then everyone who helps defeat the pit gets 50 percent of that target goal.
So we're trying to walk that line where group play isn't just like totally overwhelmingly efficient, but you're still getting something for helping each other.
Go through those pit levels.
Yeah. We heard a lot of feedback about players going like, yeah, it feels a little unrewarding to it.
Yeah.
Totally. There were some changes. In general, there, I think there's still some tension with how players feel about the efficiency of groups, which is the efficiency of solar play with awesome and things like that.
These are things we're thinking about. We have ideas on, but we want to continue to get feedback, particularly with these changes and kind of see how things play out.
Absolutely. Awesome.
We're getting questions about, you know, hey, are there any updates on social features and things like that coming to to D4?
I don't know if we have anything to share right now. Right. It's something obviously that team is very well, you guys ask all the time.
So we're very, very aware of it. And the team is been looking at it.
And once we have more to share, we'll end up sharing it with you guys. But for right now, we don't have any update.
There's questions about it. Is there, if there's plans of adding maybe potential leaderboards to the pit or anything, or is that going to be something that's just exclusively on the gauntlet?
I think the idea of adding leaderboards, other types of content over time, makes sense. Could be pretty fun.
But right now, we really want to see how the pit plays on its own. The trials feature on the challenge ladder.
We really want that to be a place where players can, or other other, plays we really want players to be able to go and compete in a very fixed environment, in a very extremely fair environment, which is like the what we really prioritize as part of the release.
The pit has pretty variable runs and runs so that it's a little more complicated. It doesn't mean that we would never add it.
I think that there's a clear indicator that there's be pretty fun to have this slightly looser leaderboard, associated with a feature like this.
Yeah. But we're going to see how things play out and we'll be thinking about how we can add more competitive features like that to the game over time.
Question from El Roqueer. I didn't pronounce that right, but when you're talking about El Roqueer, I think that is actually nailed it.
It's like an elbow game right now. Not since not everyone actually experienced PTR because PTR itself was on PC BattleNet, but they were asking when tempering can you keep previous roles?
Can you keep previous roles?
Oh, with the enchanting system.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Currently right now, we don't have the functionality to let you keep the role. Right now, if you're going to commit to re-rolling, you're going to lose that role.
You're committing to the role.
Yeah.
That's sort of like the blacksmith is hammering on that item and then locking different aspects of the weapon you sort of lose what you previously had.
But we're open to feedback, right? It's completely new feature. We really want to hear how it's playing and then ultimately what we want is a fun crafting feature.
So if that sort of feedback is really valuable.
We'll take two more and one is from Matt LOL is tempering going to allow changes for the skill type, like maybe lightning hydras or maybe changes to Blizzard where it's a rain of fire or something like that.
That's pretty cool.
Honestly, anything an app could do is open season of things we could potentially do in the future.
Not in season four, but you know, possibly in the future.
Awesome. And this is actually from a lot of space to grow.
There is a utility category that we can use a lot of space to get to.
Yeah, there's a lot of questions in here about like additional character customization options and stuff like that coming in the future.
It is like something the team is always looking at adding additional things to for players to have more choice of what they want to do, especially as they're creating characters.
And of course, being able to obtain those, like even just some things in season four of being able to get additional, you know, cosmetic things for your mount and everything like that is something that the team is most definitely looking at.
Yeah, we actually, we care about this a great deal.
I think one thing it's very interesting about Diablo 4 or a problem that we have that's very specific right is there are actually quite a few cosmetics for players to earn out on bosses and things like throughout the game.
There's lots of things for players to collect, cosmetically in the game.
But it's really hard to know that that drops off that thing in Diablo 4.
Like you can go and you can fight like a world boss 50 times and not have a drop occur for you.
Like then eventually you get your special horse like, oh, okay, it is here, but you have no idea.
It's kind of like it's hard to know exactly where to grind.
We're actually talking about that a bit on the on the dev side.
See if like there's more ways of you can kind of like make it clear where certain things can be found, which I think could be really fun.
Yeah, but I think there's work we can do there.
And also there's still work we can do about just trying to get more cool looks into the game.
So we've been talking a lot more with the various teams inside the inside Diablo 4.
And there's a broad agreement we want to bring more cool stuff to you guys.
And more cool stuff for players to find and pick up and equip and feel like it was really exciting to get that thing.
One thing we're doing like already is we're like as we develop more uniques, we're trying to make sure we have like more unique appearances to go with all of them.
We usually have like a lot of really really fun ideas.
We have to constantly play wrestling with like, alright, we only have like this X many swords, but like we have like this many ideas for swords.
And we want to try to get this into the game.
We want to wait until we have the artwork for a sword.
We usually try to make sure we've got a fun toy immediately giving you.
But we're going to make sure we're trying to get more of that stuff in game as well.
So there's just even more artwork to the unique system for players to collect.
Awesome.
So that's all the time we got right here for today.
We went over all the changes or not actually there's even more changes.
There's actually more changes in the patch and us.
We can't go through every single line in the patch notes over a stream.
So you guys can actually check out the patch and us.
There's will be available on dapple4.com.
We always have those listed on our specific patch notes page.
And those will be live immediately after this stream.
Season four, loot reborn starts on May 14th.
This is across all platforms.
It's on PC Xbox, PlayStation.
And of course if you're an Xbox and PC game pass user, you can also play dapple4 now via PC BattleNet or on your Xbox.
So lots of opportunities to play.
And of course steam, steam, can't forget steam.
Steam is also on there for PC.
That's also a platform.
That is also a game platform for everywhere.
Any other platforms you wanted to shout out?
We're everywhere.
Yeah, we're everywhere.
It's everywhere.
But again, thanks to everyone for tuning in.
We're looking forward to you guys jumping into season four, loot reborn.
And yeah, we'll see you guys in game.
And thanks again.
Thank you guys.